[Music]
[Music]
welcome it's very nice to see so many
people here which i think is a a tribute
to our speaker tonight I'm Alan Lightman
and I'm head of mi t--'s program and
writing and humanistic studies which is
part of the School of Humanities and
Social Sciences for many years now our
program has been sponsoring a writer
series in which we invite leading
thinkers and writers to the MIT campus
to talk and to read from their works
these events are all free and open to
the public tonight we are honored to
have Susan Sontag as the first speaker
and this year's writer series and I want
to thank everyone who has been involved
with planning tonight's events
I'm already dry
Susan Sontag is a national treasure
her intellectual and literary talents
span every genre her essays on American
culture for example are characterized by
insight and beautiful writing and a
deeply philosophical perspective mrs.
Santa's books include the novel's the
benefactor death kit in her recent the
volcano lover her essays have been
collected in such books as against
interpretation styles of radical will on
photography and under the sign of Saturn
and she has two book length essays
illness is metaphor and AIDS and it's
metaphors she has written and directed
four feature-length films and her new
play alison bed has been produced in
germany and will receive its American
premiere next fall she was won numerous
awards and I'll just mention a few her
book on photography won the National
Book Critics Circle Award from 1987 to
1989 she was president of the American
Center of Penn which is the
International Writers organization and
in 1990 she was awarded a very
prestigious MacArthur Fellowship as many
of you know she went to Sarajevo in July
to stage a production of Waiting for
Godot that production has been met with
much acclaim she wrote a beautiful
article describing it in a recent issue
of the New York Review of Books and she
has been named an honorary citizen of
Sarajevo we are honored to have Susan
Sontag
with us tonight
in a few minutes we are going to be
joined by another honored guest and for
security reasons I ask that none of you
leave the room once the program is
underway the event should last until
about 7:30 I'm sorry well you you can
see that I'm very calm about this whole
thing the the the event should last
until about 9:30 and if any of you think
that you cannot remain in your seats
until 9:30 then I'm going to give you
the chance to leave the room right now
so I'll wait I'll wait just a minute I
want to give you a chance to leave I
would recommend staying
okay then I'm very very happy to
introduce to you Susan Sontag
[Applause]
I want to begin this evening by doing
two things first of all I want to speak
about a friend of mine the great English
writer or perhaps I should say British
writer Salman Rushdie who has been under
sentence of death for almost five years
as many of you know on February 14th
1989 a fatwa or death sentence was
issued by the Ayatollah Khomeini of Iran
which calls on Muslims everywhere to
kill Salman Rushdie and also to kill his
publishers his translators the
booksellers his agents presumably by
extension the people who buy and read
his book there is a bounty offered of
more than two million dollars for the
assassins and there are assassins
everywhere seeking Salman Rushdie hoping
to collect this bounty
why was Salman Rushdie sentenced to
death why was a British citizen an
English citizen sentenced to death by a
religious leader in a foreign country
because he wrote a novel he wrote a
novel it wasn't even his first novel
it's a great novel but he'd written some
other great novels before it notably
Midnight's Children and between
Midnight's Children and the novel for
which he was sentenced to death
a novel called shame Salman Rushdie was
already a well-known and very admired
writer he is one of the great writers of
our time now he is famous an exemplary
for reasons that could hardly be
imagined a few years ago and we've all
had a great education thinking about the
predicament of Salman Rushdie this has
been going on as I say for almost five
years on February 14 1994 it will be
five years that Salman Rushdie has lived
in hiding under constant guard there are
assassin teams everywhere looking for
him he has had many narrow escapes he is
obliged to move from house to house this
is the life he has been living for five
years assassins have sought and in a
number of cases reached other people his
Japanese translator was murdered in July
1991
and his Italian translator I'm
practically the same day was a
coordinated assassination attempt was
severely wounded and very only luckily
and barely escaped with his life and in
October just a few weeks ago his
Norwegian publisher an assassination
attempt and also nearly successful was
made on his Norwegian publisher it's
worth mentioning that none of the people
of course who are seeking Salman
Rushdie's life to collect this Mountie
have read this book have even seen a
copy of this book and it's certainly
worth underscoring that they do not
represent the great traditions of Islam
just recently in Paris and I'm sure it
will be shortly translated into English
a hundred prominent indeed some of them
very great intellectuals and writers
from the Islamic we're
world declared their solidarity with
salman rushdie and these include for
instance of the great Egyptian novelist
mahfooz who won the Nobel Prize several
years ago the the Rushdie case raises
the most urgent issues issues that
concern all of us the book The Satanic
Verses which has been read by none of
the people who attack it and want to
murder Salman Rushdie for writing it the
book and the reactions to it are very
complex and richly emblematic but the
man the writer the human being and his
predicament his constant danger is not
emblematic at all it's absolutely real
Salman Rushdie is particularly exemplary
in his the way he has assumed his
destiny because in these very very
painful and dangerous and terrifying
five years he's gone on being a writer
he's produced another novel he is
working on i'm sure i'm omitting
something he's been so active in the
midst of all this horror he is writing
still another novel he has published a
number of extraordinary essays and given
speeches defending the basic human right
to liberty of expression he reviews
books regularly and some of you may have
seen his reviews in The New York Times
and elsewhere he even gives blurbs to
writers far too many eyes in fact I I
think but he's I can understand that he
wants to go on participating fully in
the literary world
what Salman Rushdie stands for is the
right to secularism to pluralism to
freedom of expression
to tolerance values that I hope we are
all united in supporting values I might
add for which the newest nation
state of Bosnia is also being murdered
for standing up for values of pluralism
and secularism and tolerance Salman
Rushdie is only the most visible
individual victim of a worldwide
struggle against tolerance against anti
tribal enlightened spirit of freedom as
he would be the first to say that he
would be the first to say my case stands
for many other cases as well I think
that his cause honoring his rights and
his exemplary conduct since the fatwa
should be our cause as indeed while he
lives minute by minute under constant
threat of death which is not abated he
never forgets that he's fighting not
just to stay alive but to hold back the
immense force of terror those who would
silence honesty and strangled dialogue
Salman Rushdie is is still alive but his
predicament the sentence of terror and
intimidation that has been carried out
and the worst kind of censorship is
self-censorship this case is is the
great test of where we stand on the
issue of freedom and solidarity and the
future of our own culture that's the
first thing I wanted to do to open this
evening and the second thing not
surprisingly is I want to introduce
Salman Rushdie
[Applause]
good evening my name is Mark Ryden I'm
the Provost of MIT and first I want to
thank Susan Sontag for joining us this
evening for introducing our special
guests and for making this evening
possible would you join me in thanking
her
[Applause]
unfortunately president best could not
be with us this evening owing to a prior
commitment
outside Cambridge but I'm pleased to
present on his behalf and on behalf of
the MIT community a citation and an
award to mr. Rushdie I will present the
letter that president vest has written
to mr. Rushdie and in it he says in
recognition of your outstanding
contributions to world literature and in
recognition of the independence of
thought and expression that you have
come to represent the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology proudly appoints
you honorary visiting professor of the
humanities
[Applause]
it's a real privilege for me to be on
this stage this evening so many people
have worked hard to make it possible
especially Allan Lichtman the head of
our program in writing in humanistic
studies and a needed si a person we've
been very fortunate to attract to our
faculty this is a special evening of
course we're very privileged to host
this distinguished speaker we honor him
and we celebrate our freedom of
expression
well I have to I have a lot of people to
thank first of all good evening all of
you and it's nice to be here although I
was going to apologize for the kind of
cloak-and-dagger aspect of this but but
actually Susan Sontag and I have been
looking forward to this surprise for so
long that it's actually quite nice to
pull it off and and first of all I
wanted to to thank her for being what
she described is my beard means I love
to I also of course would would like to
thank MIT for this incredible honor
which is I have to say the first
academic honor I've ever received so
it's nice to start at the top I was
saying just before we all came on here
that I was you see the plan for me is I
was supposed to be a scientist when I
was when I was 16 there's no question
that my best subjects for maths and
physics and everybody from my parents
down was assumed that that's what I
would do but at some point for reasons
of stubbornness and perversity I took a
dramatic left turn and did did history
French and Latin instead but I've always
rather regretted that loss of that
scientific dimensions it's nice to kind
of get it back free
[Laughter]
and I really do hope that that this
isn't just a symbolic moment that but
that it can be the beginning of a
long-term relationship with this with
this great institution I think many of
us writers of my generation have felt
that in many ways the cutting edge of of
the new is now to be found in the
sciences not in philosophy not in the
arts that's that actually we have a
great deal to to absorb and and and
learn from and so I look forward to
being able to do that in the company of
of all of you and of the remarkable
talents and minds present at MIT and I
think for that reason the fact that this
is such a great institution dedicated to
the search for the new and and to the
openness of thought that that search
requires I think it's it's very
appropriate and very a very great
privilege for me to receive this honor
from from of all places this this
institution and I thank them once again
for that Susan Sontag spoke so
eloquently about the issues surrounding
the so called Rushdie case that there's
not very much I want to add except you
except to endorse all the arguments she
made I just wanted to say one thing that
it's been going on for five years that's
very long time it's also long enough to
understand exactly what is going on for
a long time I think when this began the
fact that the language of censorship of
political oppression and and persecution
was wrapped in a kind of cloak of
religion meant that people did not see
it plainly and that's that's natural in
a way because that's a language which
people respect and if that language is
used to cloak evil it takes some time
for the evil inside the cloak to make
its presence felt I think it's now
perfectly clear
the nature of the nature of the evil
that lies behind such threats as the one
aimed against the Satanic Verses and I
think it's very important what Susan
pointed out that this is not just a
threat against one individual it's a
threat against if you put together all
the people involved in the production of
a book literally thousands of people in
many countries any and in fact you could
say that I am the best protected person
of all those people the shooting of
William Nygaard my very courageous
Norwegian publisher makes me feel
determined or even more determined to
try and make sure that this is the last
such atrocity and for that I'm afraid I
need your help because the only weapon
that I have is public opinion in the end
the governments of the of the Democratic
world will act in this matter
only if they believe it's a matter of
sufficient interest to their own
citizens and voters they won't do it for
me they might do it for you it's it's
therefore extremely important that the
citizens of democratic countries
understand and make plain that the case
of the murder of a writer or a publisher
or a bookseller or a translator is an is
an insult to their freedom it's not just
an act against the individual the
attempt to suppress a book is the
attempt not just to suppress the right
of a writer to write or a publisher to
publish or a translator to translate
it's also the attempt to suppress the
right of a reader to read and of all of
us to choose that which we too wish to
read so I ask you to continue to put
pressure on on your own government in
order to make sure that it as fully as
possible joins the international
campaign against this this threat for
one final reason which is that I've said
now for five years that any form of
terrorism which seems to succeed will be
repeated
here is the invention you might say of a
new form of terrorism a successor to two
aeroplanes hijacks and the taking of
hostages here we have a kind of
terrorism at a distance a kind of
remote-control terrorism which simply
points a finger across the world and
offer and asks for the the elimination
of certain individuals and offers
financial rewards and not just financial
rewards but the promise from what
dubious promise of paradise
[Music]
if this form of terrorism seems to be
working it will be repeated it and the
sad fact is that it is already being
repeated within the last few months
we've seen the assassination of the
right at our joy at Algeria the
assassination of the secularist thinker
Farraj further in Egypt the offer of
six-figure sums of dollars or for the
assassination of the writer Aziz in a
scene in Turkey and most recently the
the offer of a large sum of money by
Islamic fanatics in Bangladesh for the
murder of the young feminist novelist
Taslima Nasreen whose crime through his
so-called blasphemy was that she wrote a
novel deploring the revenge killings in
Bangladesh of Hindus by Islamic fanatics
after the destruction of the the Muslim
the mosque in ioad here in India for
this she is to be sentenced to death
here is here is evidence if ever it were
needed that this is a technique which is
beginning to look popular and the reason
it's the reason it's becoming popular is
that it seems to have worked it's
therefore important to demonstrate that
it didn't work and I think in the end
the only way you can show a terrorist
that what he is doing doesn't work is to
say I'm not scared of you the purpose of
terrorism is to terrorize the only
defense against terrorism is to refuse
to be terrorized
we have to therefore avoid our own fear
because that can do the terrorists work
for them and so it seems we are instead
of banging on for one evening of just
this evening instead of talking about
the government of Iran the subject in
which I have incredibly little interest
and instead of accepting their decision
to turn me into some kind of demonized
figure I would say I'm not that kind of
writer on this kind of writer and read
too but I thought I would read not from
the Satanic Verses just for a change
give the Satanic Verses arrest
well I'd read from an earlier novel of
mine Midnight's Children a novel which
begins like this I was born in the city
of Bombay
once upon a time no that won't do
there's no getting away from the date I
was born in dr. narlikar nursing home on
August the 15th 1947 and the time the
time matters - well then at night no
it's important to be more on the stroke
of midnight as a matter of fact clock
hands joined palms in respectful
greeting as I came Oh smell it out spell
it out at the precise instant of India's
arrival at independence I humbly forth
into the world
there were gasps and outside the window
of fireworks and crowds a few seconds
later my father broke his big toe
but his accident was a mere trifle when
set beside what had befallen me because
thanks to the occult tyrannies of those
blandly saluting clocks I had been
mysteriously handcuffed to history my
destiny is indissoluble chained to those
of my country for the next three decades
there was to be no escape soothsayers
had prophesied me newspapers celebrated
by arrival politico's ratified my
authenticity i was left
without a say in the matter I Saleem
Sinai later variously called snot-nosed
stained face Baldy sniffer Buddha and
even piece of the moon had become
heavily embroiled in fate at the best of
times a dangerous sort of involvement
and I couldn't even wipe my own nose at
the time well that's how it begins I was
I'm just going to read you a couple of
passages from later in the book they
both happen about 10 years after after
that birth Saleem by this stage what we
know about him is that he's not really
his parent style because he'd been
chained changed in this work swapped in
the hospital by accident
he's also by this stage acquired a kind
of incipient gift of telepathy which
features somewhat in what follows his
his mother or the woman who he who he
thinks is his mother has been previously
married but separated from a previous
husband is remarried he is recently
owing to his telepathic abilities and
also his habit of eavesdropping on
telephone calls
Disko discovered that she's begun to
have mysterious telephone conversations
with her with a strange man so he
decides to follow her on one of these
assignation 'he's by hiding in the trunk
of her car once upon a time there was a
mother who in order to become a mother
had agreed to change her name who set
herself the task of falling in love with
her husband bit by bit but who could
never manage to love one part the part
curiously enough which made possible her
motherhood whose feet were hobbled by
verrucas at whose shoulders were stooped
beneath the accumulating gilts of the
world whose husbands unlovable organ
failed to recover from the effects of a
freeze and who like her husband finally
succumbed to the
trees of telephones spending long
minutes listening to the words of wrong
number telephone callers shortly after
my tenth birthday
Arminius nie resumed her recent practice
of leaving suddenly and always
immediately after a wrong number on
urgent shopping trips but now hidden in
the boot of the rover they traveled with
her a stowaway who lay hidden and
protected by stolen cushions clutching a
thin strip of pink plastic in his hand
oh the suffering one undergoes in the
name of righteousness the bruising and
the bumps the breathing in of rubbery
boot air through jolted teeth and
constantly the fear of discovery suppose
she really does go shopping will will
the boot suddenly fly open we'll live
chickens be flung in feet tied together
wings clipped fluttery pecky birds
invading my hidey hole will she see me
my god I'll have to be quiet for a week
my knees drawn in beneath my chin which
was protected against bumps by an old
faded cushion I've voyaged into the
unknown in the vehicle of maternal
perfidy my mother was a cautious driver
she went slowly and turned corners with
care but afterwards I was bruised black
and blue and my IR Mary Pereira burrowed
berated me soundly for getting into
fights array god what a thing it's a
wonder they didn't smash you to pieces
completely my god what will you grow up
into you bad black man you had deep elv
on your skin and born wrestler to take
my mind off the jolting darkness I
entered with extreme caution that part
of my mother's mind which was in charge
of driving operations and as a result
was able to follow a route and also to
discern in my mother's habitually tidy
mind an alarming to suit this degree of
disorder
I was already beginning in those days to
classify people by their degree of
internal tidiness and to discover that I
preferred the Messier type whose
thoughts spilling constantly into one
another so that anticipatory images of
food interfered with the serious
business of earning a living and sexual
fantasies were superimposed upon their
political musings the bore a closer
relationship to my own Pale Male tumble
of a brain in which everything ran into
everything else and the white dart of
consciousness jumped about like a wild
flea from one thing to the next
I mean arson I whose assiduous ordering
instincts had provided her with a brain
of almost abnormal neatness was a
curious recruit to the ranks of
confusion we headed north past Breach
Candy hospital in Mahalakshmi temple
north along Hornby Villard past
Vallabhbhai Patel Stadium in [ __ ] ali's
island tomb north of what had once been
the island of bombay we were heading
towards the anonymous mass of tenements
and fishing villages and textile plants
and film studios that the city became in
these northern zones an area which was
in those days
utterly unknown to me I rapidly became
disoriented and was then obliged to
admit to myself that I was lost at last
down an unprepossessing side street full
of drainpipe sleepers and bicycle repair
shops and tattered men and boys we
stopped clusters of children assailed my
mother as she descended and she who
could never shoo away a fly handed out
small coins thus enlarging the crowd
enormous Lee eventually she struggled
away from them and headed down the
street there was a boy pleading give the
car polish Begum number one a class
Polish bigger iWatch cartel you come
they got my very fine watchman ask
anyone in some panic I listened for her
reply how could I get out of this boot
under the eyes of a guardian urgent
there was the embarrassment of it and
besides my emergence would have created
a sensation in the street my mother said
no she was disappearing down the street
the would-be polisher and watchman gave
up eventually there was a moment when
all eyes turned to watch the passing of
a second car just in case it too stopped
to disgorge a lady who gave away coins
as if they were nuts and in that instant
I had been looking through several pairs
of eyes to help me choose my moment I
performed my trick with the pink plastic
and was out in the street beside the
closed car boot in a flash setting my
lips grimly and ignoring all
outstretched palms I set off in the
direction my mother had taken a
pocket-sized sleuth with the nose of a
bloodhound
he has very big nose
and a loud drum pounding in the place
where my heart should have been and
arrived a few minutes later at the
Pioneer cafe dirty glass in the window
dirty glasses on the tables the Pioneer
cafe was not much when compared to the
Gaylords and qualities of the city's
more glamorous parts a real rut potty
joint with painted boards proclaiming
lovely lassie and fantabulous falooda
and BHEL Puri Bombay fashion with filmy
playback music blaring out from a cheap
radio by the cash till a long narrow
greeny room lit by flickering neon a
forbidding world in which broken tooth
two men sat at Wrexham covered tables
with crumpled cards and expressionless
eyes but for all its grimy decrepitude
the Pioneer cafe was a repository of
many dreams early each morning it would
be full of the best-looking
ne'er-do-wells in the city all the
wooden dolls and taxi drivers and petty
smugglers and racecourse tipsters who
had once ago once long ago arrived in
the city dreaming of film stardom of
grotesquely vulgar homes and black money
payments because every morning at 6:00
the major studios would send minor
functionary functionaries to the Pioneer
cafe to rope in extras for the day's
shooting for half an hour each morning
Wendy W Rama studios and filmistaan
talkies and RK films were taking their
pick the Pioneer was the focus of all
the city's ambitions and hopes then the
studio scouts left accompanied by the
day's lucky ones and the cafe emptied
into its habitual neon-lit torpor around
lunchtime a different set of dreams
walked into the cafe to spend the
afternoon hunched over cards and lovely
lassie and ruff theories different men
with different hopes I didn't know it
then but the afternoon pioneer was a
notorious communist party hangout it was
afternoon I saw my mother enter the
Pioneer cafe not daring to follow her I
stayed in the street pressing my nose
against a spiderwebbed corner of the
grubby windowpane ignoring the curious
glances I got because my whites
although boots stained were nevertheless
starched my hair although rumpled was
well oiled my shoes scuffed as they were
were still the plimsolls of a prosper
child I followed her with my eyes as she
went hesitantly and Veruca hobbled past
rickety tables and hard-eyed men I saw
my mother sit down at a shadowed table
at the far end of the narrow cavern and
then I saw the man who rose to greet her
the skin on his face hung in folds which
revealed that he had once been
overweight his teeth were staying with
bond he wore a clean white kurta with
Lucknow work around the buttonholes
he had long hair poetically long hanging
lank lay over his ears at the top of his
head was bald and shiny forbidden
syllables echoed in my ears nodded Nadia
that's the name of the first husband I
realized that I wished desperately that
I'd never resolved to come once upon a
time there was an underground husband
who fled leaving loving messages of
divorce a poet whose verses didn't even
rhyme after a lakh decade Lost Decade he
emerged from goodness knows where his
skin hanging loose in memory of his
erstwhile plumpness and like his
once-upon-a-time wife he had acquired a
new name now that Khan was now Qasim
Khan official candidate of the official
Communist Party of India Lara Carson
cause him the red nothing is without
meaning not without reason our blushes
red my uncle said watch out for the
Communists and my mother turned scarlet
politics and emotions were united in her
cheeks through the dirty square glossy
cinema screen of the Pioneer cafes
window
I watched ominous in eye and the no
longer now they play out their love
scene they performed with the ineptitude
of genuine amateurs on the table a
packet of cigarettes State Express 555
numbers to have significance 420 the
name given to frauds 1001 the number of
night of magic of alternative realities
a number beloved of poets and detested
by politicians for whom all alternative
versions of the world are threats and
555 which for years I believed to be the
most sinister of numbers the cipher of
the devil the great beast
Shaitan himself
but the true demonic number is not 555
but 666 yet in my mind a dark aura hangs
around the three fives to this day but I
am getting carried away suffice to say
that now their car seems preferred brand
was the aforesaid state expressed that
the figure five was repeated three times
on the packet and then the manufacturers
were WD at HBO wills unable to look into
my mother's face I concentrated on the
cigarette packet cutting from two-shot
of lovers to this extreme closeup of
nicotine but now hands enter the frame
first the hands of now they're Qasim
their poetic softness somewhat calloused
these days hands flickering like candle
flames creeping forward across rexine
then jerking back next a woman's hands
black as jet inching forward like
elegant spiders hands lifting up off the
tabletop hands hovering above three
fives beginning the strangest of dances
rising falling circling one another
weaving in and out between each other
hands longing for touch hands out
stretching tensing quivering demanding
to be but always at last jerking back
fingertips avoiding fingertips because
what I'm watching here on my dirty glass
cinema screen is after all an Indian
movie in which physical contact is
forbidden lest it corrupt the watching
flower of Indian youth and there are
feet beneath the table and faces above
it feet advancing towards feet faces
tumbling softly towards faces but
jerking away all of a sudden in a cruel
censors cut to strangers each bearing a
screen name which is not the name of
their birth act out their half unwanted
roles I left the movie before the end to
slip back into the boot of the
unpolished unwatched rover wishing I
hadn't gone to see it unable to resist
wanting to watch it all over again
what I saw at the very end my mother's
hand
raising a half-empty glass of love Lila
see my mother's lips pressing gently
nostalgically
against the mottled glass my mother's
hands handing the glass to her now there
Kassem who also applied to the opposite
side of the glass his own poetic mouth
so it was that life imitated bad art and
my film directors sister my uncle the
film directors sister brought the
eroticism of the indirect kiss into the
green neon din genus of the Pioneer cafe
to sum up in the high summer of 1957 at
the peak of an election campaign
Arminius and I blushed inexplicably at a
chance mention of the Communist Party of
India her son followed her into the
north of the city inspired on a
pain-filled scene of impotent love
questions
did I ever after that time employ the
services of pink plastic did I return to
the cafe of extras and Marxists did I
confront my mother with the heinous
nature of her offense because what
mother has any business to never mind
about what once upon a time in full view
of her only son
how could she how could she how could
she answers I did not I did not I did
not well that's a little later something
else not very pleasant happens to him
he's having about 10th year 11 Theo beg
his pardon he's already been 10 the
first mutilation of Saleem Sinai which
was rapidly followed by the second took
place one Wednesday early in 1958 the
Wednesday of the much-anticipated social
under the auspices of the anglo-scottish
education society that is to say it
happened at school
[Music]
Salim's assailant handsome frenetic with
a barbarians shaggy mustache I present
the leaping hair tearing figure of mr.
Emil zagala who taught us geography and
gymnastics and who that morning
unintentionally precipitated the crisis
of my life
Zog Allah claimed to be Peruvian and was
fond of calling us jungle Indians bead
lovers he hung a print of a stern sweaty
soldier in a pointy tin hat and metal
pantaloons above his blackboard and had
a way of stabbing a finger at it in
times of stress and shouting you see him
you savages this man is civilization you
show him respect he's got a sword and he
would swish his cane through the
stonewalled air we called him poggle's
Agha crazies igano
because for all his talk of yamas and
conquistadores and the Pacific Ocean we
knew with the absolute certainty of
rumor that he'd been born in a moussaka
in tenement and his goynes mother had
been abandoned by a decamped shipping
agent so he was not only an Anglo would
probably have passed it as well knowing
this we understood why is a gala
affected his Latin accent and also why
he was always in a fury why he beat his
fists against the stone wall walls of
the classroom but the knowledge didn't
stop us being afraid and this Wednesday
morning we knew we were in for trouble
because optional Cathedral had been
cancelled the Wednesday morning the
Wednesday morning double period was the
gallows geography class but only idiots
and boys with bigoted parents attended
it because it was also the time when we
could choose to troop off to Sir
Thomas's Cathedral in crocodile
formation a long line of boys of every
conceivable religious denomination
escaping from school into the bosom of
the Christians considerately optional
god it drove zagallo wild but he was
helpless today however there was a dark
glint in his eye because mr. Crusoe the
headmaster had announced a morning
assembly that Cathedral was canceled in
a bear scraped voice he sentenced us
said
starts to double geography and par
Gonzaga taking us all by surprise
because we hadn't realized that God was
permitted to exercise an option to
glumly we trooped into zaganos lair one
of the poor idiots whose parents never
allowed them to go to cathedral
whispered viciously into my ear you just
wait
he'll really get you guys today he
really did seated gloomily in class
gland II Keith calico fat purse fish
wallah Jinny Kapadia the scholarship boy
whose father was a taxi driver hair oil
severe methey Sonny Ibrahim Cyrus the
Great and I others too but there's no
time now because with his eyes narrowing
in delight crazy zagallo is calling us
to order human geography the girl who
announces this is what Kapadia please
sir don't know sir hands fly into the
air five belong to church band idiots
the sixth inevitably to Cyrus the Great
but zagallo is out for blood today that
godly are going to suffer filth from the
jungle he buffets Jimmy Kapadia then
begins to twist an ear casually stay in
class sometimes find out now yes sir
sorry sir six fans awaiting the Jimmy's
ear is in danger of coming off heroism
gets the better of me so please stop sir
he has a heart condition sir which is
true but the truth is dangerous because
now Cigala is rounding on me so a little
arguer is it and I am being led by my
hair to the front of the class under the
relieved eyes of my fellow pupils thank
god it's him not us I arrive in agony
beneath imprisoned Tufts so answer the
question you know what is human
geography pain fills my head
obliterating all notions of telepathic
chittery i sir no sir ouch and now it is
possible to observe a joke descending on
zagala a joke pulling his face into the
simulacrum of a smile it is possible to
watch his hand
darting forward thumb and forefinger
extended to note how
and forefinger close around the tip of
my nose and pull downwards where the
nose leads the head must follow and
finally the nose is hanging down and my
eyes are obliged to stare damply at
zagallo sandaled feet with their dirty
toenails while zagallo unleashes his wit
see boys you see what we have here
regard please the hideous face of this
primitive creature it reminds you of and
the eager responses sir the devil sir
please sir one cousin of mine no sir a
vegetable sir I don't know which until
the gallows shouting above the two
mouths eyelids sons of baboons this
object here attacked on my nose
this is human geography House aware sir
what sir the golem is laughing now you
don't see Higa force in the face of this
ugly ape you don't see the whole map of
India yes sir no sir
you show us sir see here the Deccan
Peninsula hanging down again ouch my
nose sir sir if that's the map of India
what are the stains it is gland II Keith
calico feeling bold sniggers titters
from my fellows and zagallo taking the
question in his stride these stains he
cries our Pakistan this birthmark on his
right ear is the East Wing this horrible
stain left cheek the West
remember stupid boys Pakistan is a stain
on the face of India hoho the class
laughs absolute master joke sir but now
my nose has had enough staging its own
unprompted revolt against the grasping
thumb and forefinger it unleashes a
weapon of its own
a large blob of of shining goo emerges
from the left nostril to plop into mr.
zagallo his palm fat purse fish wallah
yells look at that sir
the drip from his nose sir is that
supposed to be seal on his palm smeared
with goo Cigala loses his jokey mood
animal he curses me you see what you do
the gallows hand releases my nose
returns to her nasal refuse is wiped
into my neatly parted locks and now once
again my hair is seized
once again the hand is pulling but
upwards now and my head has jerked
upright my feet are moving on to tiptoe
and zagallo
what are you tell me what you are sir an
animal sir the hand pulls harder higher
again standing on my toenails now I Yelp
I saw an animal an animal please sir I
and still harder it's still higher once
more but suddenly it ends my feet are
flat on the ground again and the clasp
has fallen into a deathly hush sir Sonny
Ibrahim is saying you pulled his hair
out sir and now the cacophony looks up
blood he's bleeding sir please sir shall
I take him to the nurse mr. zagallo
stood like a statue with a clump of my
hair in his fist while I to shocked to
feel any pain felt the patch on my head
where mr. zagallo had created a monkish
tonsure a circle where hair would never
grow again
two days later Croker Crusoe announced
that unfortunately mr. Amiel zagala was
leaving the staff for personal reasons
but I knew what the reasons were my
uprooted hairs had stuck to his hands
like bloodstains that wouldn't wash out
and nobody wants a teacher with hair on
his palms the first sign of madness as
gland II keith was fond of saying and
the second sign is looking for him
sigalas legacy amongst Anshe and worse
than that a whole set of new taunts
which my classmates flung at me while we
waited for school buses to take us home
to get dressed for the social snot-nose
is a Baldy and sniffer has a map face
when Cyrus the Cyrus arrived in the bus
queue I tried to turn the crowd against
him by trying to set up a chant of Cyrus
the Great born on a plate in 1948 but
nobody took up the offer so we come to
the events of the Cathedral school
social at which bullies became
instruments of Destiny and fingers were
transmuted into fountains and Marsha Mir
which the legendary breaststroker fell
into a dead faint I arrived the social
with the nurtures but nurses bandaged
still on my head I was late because it
hadn't been easy to persuade my mother
to let me come so by the time I stepped
into the assembly hall beneath streamers
and balloons and the professionally
suspicious gazes of bony female
chaperones all the best girls were
already boxed stepping and Mexican
hattingh with absurdly smug partners
naturally the prefix had the pick of the
ladies
I watched them with passionate Envy Gaz
de and Joshi and Stevenson and wish the
personal appearance tally are fun and
died happily and Jessa Walla and Wagle
I tried butting in on them during excuse
me s but when they saw my bandage and my
cucumber of a nose and the stains on my
face they just laughed and turned their
backs hatred burgeoning in my bosom
I ate potato chips and drank bubble up
and winter and told myself those jerks
if they knew who I was they'd get out of
my way pretty damn quick but still the
fear of revealing my true telepathic
nature was stronger than my somewhat
abstract desire for the whirling
European girls hey Salim isn't it Eggman
what happened to you I was dragged out
of my bitter solitary reverie by a voice
behind my left shoulder a low throaty
voice full of promises but also of
menace
a girl's voice I turned with a sort of
jump and found myself staring at a
vision with golden hair and a prominence
and famous chest my god she was 14 years
old why was she talking to me
my name is Masha neova CH the vision
said I've met your sister of course of
course I know I started I I know your
name and I know yours she straightened
my tie so that's fair over her shoulders
I saw Blandy Keith and fat purse
watching us in drooling paroxysms of
envy I straightened my back and pushed
out my shoulders marShon ear which asked
again about my bandage it's nothing I
said in what I hoped was a deep voice a
sporting accident
and then working feverishly to hold my
voice steady would you like to to dance
okay said Marsh a mere [ __ ] but don't
try any smooching Selene takes the floor
with Marsha a mere which swearing not to
smooch Selim and Marsha doing the
Mexican hat Marsha and Selene box
stepping with the best of them I allow
my face to adopt a superior expression
you see you don't have to be a prefect
to get a girl the dance ended and still
on top of my wave of elation I said
would you care for a stroll you know in
the quad
Marsha near which smiling privately well
yeah just for a sec but hands off okay
hands off Selim swells Selim and Marsha
taking the air man this is fine this is
the life gland II Keith calico and fat
purse fish wallah
step out of the shadows of the
Quadrangle they are giggling hee hee
Marsha near which looks puzzled as they
block our path whoo-hoo fat purse says
Marsha who some date you got that and I
shut up you whereupon climb D Keith you
want to know how he got his war wound
Marsha and fat purse hee hee hee Marsha
says don't be crude
he got it in a sporting accident fat
person Glenda Keith are almost falling
over with mirth and then fish voila
reveals all zagallo pulled his hair out
in class hee hoo ha at Keith snot-nose
is a Baldy and both together the sniffer
has got a map face
there is puzzlement on Marsha you
[ __ ] face and something more some
budding spirit of sexual mischief Selene
they're being so rude about you yes I
say ignore them I try to edge her away
but she goes on you aren't going to let
them get away with it
there are beads of excitement on her
upper lip her tongue is in the corner of
her mouth the eyes of Marsha Mir which
say what are you a man or a mouse and
under the spell of the champion
breaststroker something else floats into
my head and now I am rushing at calico
and fish wallah while they are
distracted by giggles my knee drives
into gland ease groin before he's
dropped a similar genuflection has laid
fat purse low I turned to my mistress
she applauds softly hey man pretty good
but now my moment has passed and fat
purse is picking himself up and Landy
keith is moving towards me abandoning
all pretense of manhood I turn and run
and the two bullies are after me and
behind them comes Marsha a mere [ __ ]
calling where are you running little
hero
but there's no time for her now mustn't
let them mustn't let them get me into
the nearest classroom try and shut the
door but fat purses foot is in the way
and now the two of them are inside - and
I - at the door I grab it with my right
hand trying to force it open get out if
you can they are pushing the door shut
but I'm pulling with the strength of my
fear I have it opened a few inches my
hand curls round it and now fat purse
slams all his weight against the door
and it shuts too fast for me to get my
hand out of the way and it's shut a thud
and outside Marsha a mere which arrives
and looks down at the floor and sees the
top third of my middle finger lying
there like a lump of well chewed
bubblegum this was the point at which
she fainted
no pain everything very far away fat
person gland e Keith are fleeing to get
help or to hide I look at my hand out of
curiosity my finger has become a
fountain red liquid spurts out to the
rhythm of my heartbeat never knew a
finger held so much blood pretty
now here's nurse don't worry nurse only
a scratch
your parents are being phoned mr. Crusoe
is getting his car keys nurse is putting
a great wad of cotton wool over the
stump it's filling up like red candy
floss and now Crusoe
get in the car saline your mother is
going straight to the hospital yes sir
and the [ __ ] has anybody got the [ __ ]
yes headmaster here it is thank you
nurse probably no use but you never know
hold this while I Drive saline and
holding up my severed fingertip in my
unmute elated left hand I am driven to
the hospital through the echoing streets
of night at the hospital
whitewalls stretches everyone talking at
once words pour around me like fountains
oh god preserve us my little piece of
the moon what have they done to you -
which old Crusoe mrs. C knife accidents
will happen both boys will be boys but
my mother enraged what kind of school
mr. caruso I'm here with my son's finger
at pieces and you tell me not good
enough no sir and now while Crusoe
actually the names like like Robinson
you know the doctor is approaching and
the question is being asked whose answer
will change the world
mrs. C nigh your blood group please the
boys lost blood transfusion may be
necessary and Amna I am a my husband oh
now she's crying
breaking down still the doctor in that
in that case are you aware of your son's
but she the doctor's daughter must admit
she cannot answer the question alpha or
Omega well in that case a very quick
test with on the subject of rhesus my
mother through her tears both my husband
and I rhesus positive and the doctor
well good that at least but when I am on
the operating table just sit there son
I'll give you a local anesthetic no
madam he's in shock
total anesthesia would be impossible all
right son just hold your finger up keep
it still helped him nurse it'll be over
in a jiffy while the surgeon is sewing
up the stump and performing the miracle
of transplanting the roots of the nail
all of a sudden there's a fluster in the
background million miles away and have
you got a second mrs. C no and I can't
hear properly words float across the
infinite distance this is seen I are you
sure oh and a and oh this is positive
both of you heterozygous or homozygous
no there must be some mistake
how could I'm sorry it's absolutely
clear neither a no excuse me madam but
he is you're not adopted the hospital
nurse interposes herself between me and
the miles away chatter but it's no good
because now my mother is shrieking but
of course you must believe me doctor my
god of course he's our son neither a nor
oh and the rhesus factor impossibly
negative and i gossiped e offers no
clues and present in the blood rare Kell
antibodies and my mother crying crying
crying crying I don't understand
a doctor's daughter and I don't
understand have Alpha and Omega unmasked
me Wiz is rhesus pointing it's
unanswerable finger and will Mary
Pereira be obliged to confess I wake up
in a cool white venetian blinded room
with All India Radio for company Tony
Brent is singing red
sails in the sunset my father our Madson
I his face ravaged by whiskey and now by
something worse
stands beside the venetian blind Amina
speaking in whispers again I hear
snatches across the million miles of
distance please thank you now what are
you saying of course it was of course
you are
how could you think I would who could it
have been oh god don't just stand there
look at me I swear I swear on my
mother's head no she's a new song from
Tony Brent whose repertoire today is
uncanny how much is that doggy in the
window hags in the air floating on radio
waves
my father advances on me towers over me
I've never seen him look like this
before
Abba and he I should have known just
look where am I in that face that nose I
should have known he turns on his heel
and leaves the room my mother follows
him too distraught to whisper now no I
won't let you believe such things about
me I'll kill myself
I'll and the door swings shut behind
them
there is a noise outside like a clot or
a slap
most of what matters in your life takes
place in your absence
Tony Brent begins crooning his latest
hit into my good ear and a shows shows
me melodiously that the clouds will soon
roll by I'll do for him
[Applause]
well you can stand another while to read
another one um I read those faster than
I usually do this is that this is a
short story so I thought at least I
could read one small complete piece of
work this is more recent short story not
about India this is a short story with a
very long title it's called it's called
Christopher Columbus and Queen Isabella
of Spain consummated their relationship
Santa Fe January 1492 Columbus a
foreigner follows Queen Isabella for an
eternity without entirely giving up hope
in what characteristic postures proud
yet supplicant the head held high but
the knee bent fawning yet fearless
possessed of a certain source eval
Garrity he gets away with it by virtue
of his confidence man's charm however as
time passes the ingratiating aspects of
his stance are emphasized the sea dog
ravish nurse wears a little thin as do
his shoes his hope it is of what obvious
answers first he hopes for preferment he
wants to tie the Queen's favor to his
helmet like a knight in a romance
he owns no helmet he has hopes of cash
and of three tall ships Nina Pinta Santa
Maria of in 1492 sailing across the
ocean blue but on his first arrival at
court when the Queen herself asked him
what he desired he bowed over her olive
hand and with his lips a millimeter away
from the great ring of her power he
murmured a single dangerous word
consummation
these unspeakable foreigners the nerve
consumation indeed and then following in
her footsteps
month after month as if he stood a
chance his course epistles his tuneless
serenades beneath her casement windows
obliging her to have them closed
shutting out the cooling breeze she had
better things to do a world to conquer
and so forth who did he think he was
foreigners can be dogged now and also on
account of language difficulties failed
to take a hint
then again let us not forget it is
considered dirigir to keep a few
foreigners around they lend the place a
certain cosmopolitan tone
they are often poor and consequently
willing to perform divers necessary but
dirty jobs they are moreover a warning
against complacency their existence in
our midst reminding us that there are
quarters in which hard as it is to
accept we ourselves would be considered
foreigners too but to speak so to the
Queen
foreigners forget their place having
left it behind given time they begin to
think of themselves as our equals it is
an unavoidable hazard they introduced
into our austerities their Italianate
blandishments nothing for it turn a deaf
ear look the other way they rarely mean
real harm and go too far only
infrequently the Queen be assured can
look after herself Columbus at
Isabella's Court is quickly burdened
with the reputation of a crazy man
his clothes are excessively colourful
and he drinks also to excess when
Isabella wins a military victory she
celebrates it with eleven days of Psalms
and the sonorous severity of priests
Columbus crashes about outside the
Cathedral
waving a wineskin he is a one-man
debauch see him that drunkard with his
huge shaggy head filled with nonsenses a
fool with a glittering eye dreaming of a
golden paradise beyond the western edge
of things
consummation the queen plays with
Columbus she promises him everything he
wants at luncheon and cuts him dead
later the same afternoon looking through
him as if he were a veil on his Saints
day she summons him into her inmost
boudoir dismisses her girls permits him
to braid her hair and for a moment
to fondle her breasts then she summons
her guards for forty days she banishes
him to the stables and piggeries he sits
forlorn on horse munched hay while his
thoughts run on distant fabled gold he
dreams of the queen's perfumes but
awakes gagging in a pigsty toying with
columbus pleases the queen and pleasing
the queen he reminds himself may help
him to achieve his purposes pigs rout
all by his feet he grits his teeth
pleasing the queen is good that she
torment him merely for sport oh because
he is foreign and she is unused to his
ways and meanings oh because her ring
finger still hot with the memory of his
lips his breath has been how you say
touched tentacles of warmth spread
backwards from her finger towards her
heart but turbulence has been aroused oh
because she is torn between the
possibility of embracing his scheme with
a lover's abandon and the more
conventional and differently maliciously
pleasurable option of destroying him by
laughing finally after much for play in
his foolish supplicant face Columbus
consoles himself with possibilities not
all possibilities are consoling however
she is an absolute monarch her husband
is an absolute zero a blank a blank
couldn't be colder we will not speak
further of him she is a woman whose ring
is often kissed it means nothing to her
she is no stranger to blandishments she
resists them effortlessly she is a
tyrant two numbers among her possessions
a private menagerie of 419 fools some
grotesquely malformed others as
beauteous as the dawn he Columbus is
merely her four hundred and twentieth
idiot he is her clown her performing
flea this too is a plausible scenario
either she understands him his dream of
a world beyond the world's end so
profoundly that she spooked by it she
turns first towards it then away oh she
doesn't understand him at all nor cares
to understand take your pick
what certain is that he doesn't
understand her only the facts are plain
she is Isabella all-conquering queen he
is her invisible though raucous
multicolored wine bibbing man
consummation the sexual appetites of the
male decline those of the female
continue with the advancing years to
grow isabella is Columbus's last hope he
is running out of possible patrons sales
talk flirtatiousness hair steam time
drags by isabella gallops around winning
battles expelling Moors from their
strongholds her appetites expanding by
the week the more of the land she
swallows the hungrier she gets the more
Warriors she engulfs the hungrier she
gets Columbus aware of a slow shriveling
inside him scolds himself he should see
things as they are
he should come to his senses what chance
does he have here some days she makes
him clean the latrines on other days he
is on body washing duty and after a
battle the bodies are not clean soldiers
going to war we're man-sized nappies
under their armor because the fear of
death will open the bowels we'll do it
every time
Columbus was not cut out for this sort
of work it is getting him nowhere he
tells himself to leave Isabella once and
for all but there are problems he's
advancing years the patron shortage once
he D camps he will have to forget the
Western voyage the body of philosophical
opinion whichever's that life is absurd
has never appealed to him he is a man of
action revealing himself by deeds but
without the possibility of the voyage he
will be obliged to accept the
meaninglessness of life this too would
be a defeat invisible in hot tropical
colors unrequited
he remains dogging her footsteps hoping
for the ecstasy of her glance the search
for money and patronage Columbus says is
not so different from the quest for love
she is omnipotent castles fall at her
feet
the Jews are being expelled the Moors
prepare their last surrender the queen
is at Granada riding at her armies head
she overwhelms nothing she has wanted
has ever been refused all her dreams are
prophecies acting upon information
received while sleeping she draws up her
invincible battle plans foils the
conspiracies of assassins learns of the
infidelities and corruptions for which
she blackmails both her loyalists to
ensure their support and her opponents
to ensure there's the dreams help her
forecast the weather negotiate treaties
and invest shrewdly in trade she eats
like a horse and never gains an ounce
the earth adores her footfall its
shadows flee before the brilliance of
her eyes her face is a lush peninsula
set in a sea of hair her treasure chests
are inexhaustible her ears are soft
question marks suggesting some
uncertainty her legs her legs are not so
great she is full of discontent no
conquest satisfies her no peak of
ecstasy is high enough see there at the
gates of the Alhambra is Bob deal the
unlucky the last Sultana of the last
redoubt of all the centuries of Arab
Spain behold now at this very instant he
surrenders the keys to the Citadel into
her grasp there and as the weight of the
keys falls from his hand into hers she
she yawns
Columbus gives up hope while isabella is
entering the Alhambra in listless
triumph he is saddling his mule while
she dawdles in the courtyard of the
lions he departs in a frenzy of whips
elbows hooves all rapidly obscured by a
dust cloud invisibility claims him he
surrenders to its will knowing he is
abandoning his destiny he abandons it he
rides away from Queen Isabella in
hopeless fury rides day and night and
when his mule dies under him he
shoulders his ridiculous gypsy patchwork
bags they're rowdy colors muted now by
dirt and walks around him stretches the
lush plain her armies have subdued
Columbus sees none of it not the lands
fertility nor the sudden Baroness of the
vanquished castles looking down from
their pinnacles the ghosts of defeated
civilizations flow unnoticed down the
rivers Gwadar this and Gwadar that their
names retaining an echo of the
annihilated past overhead the arabesque
Wheeling's of the patient buzzards Jews
pass Columbus in long columns but the
tragedy of their expulsion makes no mark
on him somebody tries to sell him a
Toledo sword he waives the man away
having lost his own dream of ships
Columbus leaves the Jews to the ships of
their exile wait waiting in the harbor
of Cadiz exhaustion strips him of his
senses this old world is too old and the
new world is an unfound land the loss of
money and patronage Columbus says is as
bitter as unrequited love he walks
beyond fatigue beyond the limits of
endurance and the frontiers of self and
somewhere along this path he loses his
balance falls off the edge of his sanity
and out here beyond his mind's rim he
sees for the first and only time in his
life a vision it is the dream of a dream
he dreams of his Abela languidly
exploring
the Alhambra the great jewel she has
seized from Bob Dylan us reads she is
staring into a large stone bowl held
aloft by stony lions the bowl is filled
with blood and in it she sees Columbus
Dreams her seeing a vision of her own
the bowl shows her that everything all
the known world is now hers everyone in
it is in her hands to do with as she
pleases and when she understands this
Columbus Dreams the blood at once
congeals becoming a thick and verminous
sludge whereupon the Isabella of
Columbus's weary but also vengeful
imaginings is shaken to her marrow by
the realization that she will never
never never be satisfied by the
possession of the known only the unknown
perhaps even the unknowable can satisfy
her and at once she remembers Columbus
he envisions her remembering him the
invisible man who dreams of entering the
invisible world the unknown perhaps even
unknowable world beyond the edge of
things beyond the stone bowl of the
everyday beyond the thick blood of the
sea Columbus in this bitter dream makes
Isabella see the truth at last makes her
accept that her need for him is as great
as his need for her yes she knows it now
she must must must give him the money
the ships anything and he must must must
carry her flag and her favour beyond the
end of the end of the earth into
exaltation and immortality linking them
forever with bonds far harder to
dissolve than those of any mortal love
the harsh and defying ties of history
conservation Isabella in Columbus is
savage dream tears her hair runs from
the courtyard of the Lions screams for
her heralds find him she commands but
Columbus in his dream refuses to be
found
he wraps around himself the dusty
patchwork cloak of his invisibility and
the Herald's gallop hither and yon in
vain is Isabella screeches beseeches
implores [ __ ] [ __ ] how do you like it
now Columbus sneers by absenting himself
from her Court by this final and
suicidal invisibility he has denied her
her heart's desire serves her right
[ __ ] she murdered his hopes didn't she
well then in doing so she has laid
herself low as well
poetic justice fair's fair at the dreams
end he permits the messengers to find
him there hoofbeats they're waving
frantic arms they plead cajole offer
bribes but it's too late only the sweet
self lacerating joy of murdering
possibility remains he answers the
herald a shake of the head no he comes
to his senses he is on his knees in the
fertility of the plains waiting for
death he hears the hoofbeats approaching
and raises his eyes half expecting to
see the exterminating angel riding
towards him like a conqueror it's black
wings the boredom on its face
Isabella's Herald surround him they
offer him food drink a horse good news
they shout the Queen has summoned you
your voyage wonderful news she saw a
vision and it scared her all her dreams
are prophecies she ran from the
courtyard of the Lions shouting for you
the heralds report she will send you
beyond the stone bowl of the known world
beyond the thick blood of the sea she is
waiting for you in Santa Fe
you must come at once he stands up like
a required lover like a groom on his
wedding day he opens his mouth and what
almost spills out is the bitter refusal
No
yes he tells the Herald's yes I'll come
[Applause]